let me understand this whole thing with
that sheeran so krista miller the
actress goes to nobu me ted sheeran she
brings that sharon over to your house
and you're hanging out with ed ed's
talking to you
and he says wait a second you're single
i got a guy for you
johnny my writing partner we write songs
together right well what happened was ed
said can i have some friends over this
weekend i'd say of course and he invited
johnny
gary lightbody you know both of them
from snow patrol
taylor swift
uh
just some great musicians and they all
came over and i had a fun group anyway
it was like sasha baron cohen and isla
fisher and jennifer was there this is
unbelievable oh yeah it was great yeah
it was really fun
and everyone's sleeping over your place
not johnny and gary and ed was but and
taylor swift did not stay over but so we
all woke up the next morning
and everybody had traded numbers uh you
know let's stay in touch and nobody
asked me for my number i mean this is
worse than not getting
nominated nobody wanted
you're this great person i've hung with
you but i think i'm more stick and move
i don't sit and have these deep
conversations i want everyone to be
happy so i'm making sure you have a
drink and i'm so i there's something
about me i don't know why anyways we're
kind of making fun of the fact that i
don't do this and i had looked i
remember seeing johnny and going oh wow
he's really he's intense he's got those
eyes and he was playing the piano and
then i thought oh he's really
really handsome but i didn't do anything
about it then then i had the screening
of this movie i directed and i heard
aila say something to joe that friend of
ours and oh yeah she was at the house
she's like you know she was single at
the time you should go try to flirt with
johnny and i went whoa whoa whoa isla
what are you doing
if
anybody's gonna try to flirt with johnny
well what's wrong with me
and so isla went up to sasha and said
sasha courtney wants to go out with
johnny so sasha walks up to gary and
johnny and this i'm gonna cuss now and
say
hey um courtney wants to [ __ ] one of you
from snow patrol
what a hollywood story i know and i
didn't it wasn't like i said i want to
[ __ ] johnny no i understand yeah this
guy sasha baron cohn is a funny guy
just to go over and do that were you
dying inside that he did that i mean you
must have been terribly embarrassed and
this is really weird harry styles was in
the conversation
and harry's like if you don't ask her
out i think he like threatened to do
something crazy like i'm gonna i don't
know if i forgot what it was it's pretty
bad but anyways at that he called me i
think the next day or wrote me and then
we went on a date a week later is johnny
going to propose at some point courtney
what do we where are we at with this
whole thing let's be honest we never
talk about it ever i don't think about
it uh um i mean it's really we've been
engaged
but
we don't i don't know it's i guess it's
irrelevant you're right irrelevant i
don't think about
getting married i love his family i love
i mean i love him i love you know his
what he does